YO THAT
IFFERENT TAKES ON
WOULD S WE
OF T TWOHLHT IN SU TODAY IN TH
CONGRESSME DT
RENEES
OUSSF Y
THEYL OF THE HOUSE.
TH AMERICAN PEOPLE NEED TO KNOW
THAT THE HAVE TO HRYAN TO SAHE S
HI NEED SOME MORE TIME
CAOK AT THDA.
YOU'RE LOOKING AT ANY DATA.LOBBG
DYIN'VE GOTREN.
ARMY TEACHER. THATORY TEACHER SL
COUNSE, PRINCIPAL. I WAS IN CAFY
WERSHOOTING, NEVER SHOOTIN T
US.HYOD
PROTECT THEM? SAY YOU'VE
THERS  ACTM MERICAN AND ELECTEDE
SIDE. I'M A RUBLICAN. I
SENDNSIBLEE IN THE
AMERICANS SUPPORT BACKGROUND
CHECKS. FOR EXAMPLE
S
. I REJECT WHOLEHEARTEDLYT
THERE ISN'TTH EALS CAN DO TOING.
BY THE FACT THAT T, WERE LE
GE K T
SOTE ON G R CLEARLY ISN'T
WHAPISTOO OFTEN THE RIGHT RETREL
ALNER SCHOOLS AND
THEN LS NLY THE GUNS GIVE J B
TO COMMIT THECT. IT'S BOTH
SOMEBODY
A
CHILDREN. YOU HAVE TOE N
B
CONGRESS. IF YOU'RE
NOT WILLI
PEOP S WE'RE NNGHING W
T. BUT YOU BOTH
HERE'S SOMNE A
NGRESSMAHEE'TH THIS IS CONGRESSN
ON GUNEGON.
HE IS, UM,ROM NASHVILLE. I
BELIEVE SO LISTEN TO HIM TODAY.
THREE. PRECIOUS LITTLE KIDS L
THEIR LIS, BELIEVE THREE
ADULTS ANDN TCOUR, , TOO.
IT'S A HORRIBLE
SITUATION, AND WE'RE NOT GOING
TO FIX ARE GOING
TO BE CLS, AY DADDY
FOUGHT THE SECOND WORLD WAR IN
THE PACIFIC JAPANESE AND HE T
. HSOMEBODYAN TO KE YOU OUT
AND D'TIRERE'SOFOT IT.
YOU KNOWMY FATHER WAS DRAFTEDE E
IN THE ARMY IN 1945ON'T
THE SAME SENTIMENT AS THAHER, WD
IN WORLD WAR T.
TAKI THE WRONG MESSAGE FHER W IE
JAPABT HIS FATHE
, YOU KNOW, BUT THINK THAT NOERE
THIS ULTIMATY NDS
OF THE VOTERHE ARE
THE CONGRESS. THE VOTERS AHEBACG
STATES WHERE BASICALLY
BAOU
EYNGRLING AT TH OFMARKET
THE DAY. IF VER
RY
ONES WHOONAL. AND THERE, THEY'RE
THON CTR
WHO E
AR FIRM IN TH, WAS SOME SORLOOSI
GENERAL CAME OUT
AND SAMS BE
A CONNEC BOBNCER. THEY WENT  HBN
FULLL,ION
BECAUSE ANYONE HURT THEIRLIAD TO
W WDI
CIGARETTES? AND THE THING
IS THE PR IS
GETTING WORSE, RIGHT? WE'VE H
TH'S MORE THAN ANYTH
T FOR IN FACT,
20IT ATIN NUMBER OF MASS SHOOTID
SO IAN OF WE
CAN'T DOTWORKING THEIR PLAN  D
WOULD SAY I THINK
THERE ISN TE IN TH
THE GUN REFORM THROUGH
AND EVEN CHRIS MURPHY O CNN THE
OTHERYO
GONNA BE ABLE TO DO YOU
ASSAAULTHE EVED THEN
LET'S PUT
MORE
GRCKSE ONE TULD PASS THEAT
ERING ON BOTH
HOUSE HAS DISTRICTS
SO RR  BE
NO ROOM FOR COMP ON AN
ISSUEHING THAT
CO ACTUALLY PASS THROUGH
INTETWRS AND THE REPUBLICAN
LEGISLATORS WHO RSETALKINGTODAYD
U YS
HETHI
THAT WE LOOK N N
RECE W ARE DIFFE, WHO
GRBE, SN
AT THE HI D A
HAGULTAIN'T O STOP THAT. BUT
HEY'RE
IN THIN HAD SOMEONE UNDER
DOCTORASED SEVEN
WE UM WELL, CLEA THERE
CREAVE T ON
UNDER CARE WHO'S ON SUICIDEOUT Y
WAS ABLEO ON. BUT BUT BUTHE IST
IS WHAT N PURPORT T REPRE?KING S
THEY SAYTUI'D BE FINE
OF. THEREISCONNECT AS I'M A
REPUBLIC AND A GUN OWNER, AND
NEED MORACKS AND THAT THERE ARE
ACTIONS THAT WE T THA
IT'S SNIQUELY AME
PROBLEM. THAT DOESN'T HAPPE THEA
WIWI VOTE'M SUGGESTINHAT REPUBLS
DEMOCRAT. WHAT I'MUGGESTING IS
USE YOUR PRIMARY MORE
TE FOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE GOING UP TO DRAG
SROUND THE PAY ATTEN TALL T ISS.
HELP SOLVE THIS PROB.  A
GREAT POINT. BECAUSE TEES
IS DEFINEL D